Joseph Powers who's a principal data
scientist talking about how to win
friends and influence people with
data uh welcome to my talk
um so pretty early in my data science
career I was introduced to a worrying
statistic uh when I was told that 80% of
data science projects never successfully
go into
production uh this is an unverifiable
statistic but uh I I I think you related
to it or you would not have shown up for
the talk um and this is worrying because
you know we invest a lot of time in a
data science project a lot of uh you
know your personal time a lot of company
resources um and you know looking back
on six years in hindsight the bad news
is that this is probably true if not an
underestimate um of how many projects
fail to go to production successfully um
but the good news is that I think you
can reliably be among the 20% whose
projects do successfully go to
production if you implement the steps
from this
talk so we could start off with why
wouldn't you know a data science project
go to production after all the expense
invested in it um one of the first
reasons is that many launch ready
projects die in the backlog awaiting
prioritization uh second many projects
get deployed but their potential
adopters are unaware of their
existence uh and finally even for
projects that get deployed people are
aware of them uh the difficulty of using
those projects can incede uh the
incentives uh to use those same
projects so how do you ensure that your
data science project goes into
production and gets widely
adopted um I have found an enormous
amount of value uh from a small book
written 90 years ago called How to Win
Friends and Influence People
um this is a book that kept getting
recommended over and over again for
probably two decades before I finally
picked it up and I think it took me a
long time to pick it up because my
initial reaction to the title was ick
you know um it sounds like a sharmy
manipulative way to deal with leaders
and colleagues um but if you I highly
encourage you to if you actually open
the book uh what you'll find is that
it's about empathy uh it's a book about
winning over colleagues and influencing
leaders by listening to and designing
around their needs uh and I think it's a
really productive approach to working
with people who have different needs
than you uh and who have different
agendas and different goals and they're
equally valid with your own but they are
different so step one uh influence
leadership this is the first step in any
successful data science project
launch you need to start by identifying
a problem worth solving uh and for me it
into it this focused around AB testing
and some of you may not be as familiar
with what AB testing looks like in
Industry so I'll anchor with a small
example uh this was uh a race mode timer
that we tested in last tax
season very simple uh in recipe a you
get no timer this is your control
condition recipe B uh you get a
predicted duration of your tax filing
and you have a timer running against it
and it's just a simple question you know
does this feature uh increase the
probability that you'll complete your
tax
so in 2022 our AB tests on average were
taking 30 to 60 days to complete uh and
in you know a precious traffic window
like tax season that's a lot of lost
opportunity so reducing AB test duration
by 25% became among the company's top
goals so after identifying problem worth
solving now you need to sell your
solution to leadership in terms that
they understand and already care about
so these terms should not be abstract
statistical terms or mathematical proofs
you should and I highly encourage you to
do that for yourself to convince
yourself that this is a valid and
sustainable solution but that's not
going to be the pitch to
leadership um the terms that they care
about are often going to be time and
money so how does your solution save
your customers time or how is it going
to optimize their tax refund
alternatively how does this solution say
our employees time or how is it going to
make money for the business uh these are
the kinds of terms that are going to
highly motivate and get the attention of
your leaders to back your proposed
solution so got a relevant problem 30 to
60 days needed for fixed sample AB
tests and I have a proposed solution uh
that was to increase test speed with
sequential AB testing so fix samples
tests these are your classic you know uh
Fisher T tests uh Ki Square um there's a
fixed sample needed before you can
perform a valid analysis uh sequential
AB testing uh is a suite of methods but
it allows you to look at the data either
every day or at fixed periods without
undermining the Integrity of the
test it's not just peing on a fixed
sample test this is a a valid way to to
to look at the data
early um okay so how do you win
leadership support for a solution like
this
um Again by demonstrating time money
benefits also in familiar business
scenarios you're going to want to avoid
examples like dice games and marbles in
a jar um you know anchor it to the kind
of business context that they're already
familiar with uh and these are the
actual slides that I used to sell our
senior leadership that sequential
testing was a promising Way Forward so
um what I did is I simulated thousands
of uh AB testing scenarios and then I
just observed the performance of fixed
sample tests against the sequential
testing methods that I was proposing so
in the first case um how much faster
would our sequential tests end when no
effect is present so we're testing a
versus B but because I wrote the
simulations I know there is absolutely
no real difference between these two
conditions how much faster will
sequential tests
end so on my y AIS I have a tally of the
simulated tests on my xaxis I have the
sample size when those sequential tests
ended and then in the dotted line I have
for reference I have the fixed sample
size that would have been required under
these testing conditions so in this case
it was 31,000 how long would the
sequential tests end uh on average when
no effect was present uh a sequential
test was taking just 14,000
samples uh to conclude this is a 60%
Time Savings over a fixed sample test
and there's is a long tail nothing's
free in life but by the time you reach
your fixed sample size 91% of your tests
have concluded so I think this is a very
worthwhile tradeoff this is just when no
effect is
present well another familiar business
scenario how much faster would
sequential tests end if a small
Improvement was present say like a 1%
lift so same plot again and the fixed
sample test always takes the same amount
of time it's a fixed sample under these
testing conditions a fixed sample takes
the same amount of
time um but now when the 1% lift is
present on average we're taking just
18,000 samples of 40% savings compared
to the fixed sample
test uh and finally we could look at how
much faster sequential tests end when a
treatment is harmful so you know you
never want to do this but this is also
why we AB test we don't want to roll out
features that hurt the customer so if
you roll out something an unintentional
it has a 1% uh you know
harm uh now you get enormous savings uh
just 5,000 samples on average and 100%
of the tests are ending faster than the
fixed sample required that's an 85% Time
Savings as an 85% reduction in the
number of customers who are exposed to
an unintentionally uh unhelpful feature
I I think this slide alone may have sold
leadership that this was a method worth
pursuing
but again I just want to emphasize
there's no fancy statistical terms being
used um you know we did our homework we
did the mathematical proofs but that's
not the pitch when you're selling it to
leadership you want to put this in terms
that they already care about and
understand um so for the summary on
influencing leadership um you need to
sell your Solution by identifying a
problem worth
solving pitching a solution in terms
that they already care
about and building trust in your data
science solution through simulated data
trials in very familiar business
scenarios uh and then this closes this
section closes with you need to leave
with a clear endorsement from leadership
for adoption of your
solution um and they're going to be
eager to get behind it I think you
actually need to be thinking ahead to
part two which is how fast can you roll
out your solution uh once they get
behind uh your
proposal
and so this brings us to step two
winning over your
colleagues so leaderships Endor Your
solution and they're now asking like
great we want to endorse this we want
people to adopt it you don't want this
to be something that's jammed down your
colleagues throat uh or is just
miserable for them to implement and this
is where design is going to come in
heavily is where your colleagues are
concerned you want to design a
userfriendly tool and then provide
adequate support for
adoption
excuse
me um so I can proudly say our first
sequential testing apps were
unusable um but luckily we had done lots
of user testing with the analysts that
into it and they told us this early on
they would say things like I don't even
know where to look I don't know where to
start uh I don't know what I should
do and so we took this feedback we heard
it but we didn't really know how to act
on it and that's where like the second
book uh recommendation in this
presentation comes in which is the
Design of Everyday Things um
philosophically this is very closely
aligned with how to win friends and
influence people uh same theme again
like you have your needs you have your
agenda but you need to recognize that
the people you're trying to influence
may have different needs uh and see
those validly and meet them halfway so
um you know you don't need to read the
whole book I think the first three
chapters alone are enough to provide the
framework for how to navigate these
design
challenges um and it's going to allow
you to combine your vision of how you
want people to use your app or data
science project with their feedback
about how they expected to use the app
and you can make a wonderful halfway
meeting
point and this is what it looked like
for us okay
um so when you come to the app you know
we were acting to people were like I
don't know where to look we used to hit
them with everything all at once so now
we did a scaffolded introduction to the
app first question you get asked where
are your test data are they in the data
Lake are they in a CSV
file uh second it's often going to be
several months between your release of
an application or project the training
associated with it and when they
actually go to use it so just expect
that they'll have forgotten 95% of
everything they that you told them and
so we always include a hyperlink uh to
the original training materials where
they can see a recording and a brief
Wiki um it's good lesson from uh the
book is when your Wiki is getting really
long that's a clue you need to go back
and redesign the product but so after
they've provided us with uh their data
location uh we do a quick validation
that the data are in the correct
structure for the app to
ingest uh and then we ask them a few
questions about uh their data so for
instance what is your control name what
is the primary metric you're evaluating
your ab test with and what is your
minimum detectable
effect after We Gather this data from
them we run the
analysis and in the upper uh upper right
and bold green you get a clear call to
action so our recommendation is that you
stop the experiment for Revenue your
power has exceeded 80% uh which is off a
widely used power threshold uh and in
the lower right um You can see the
decisions so in this case recipe B is
offering a statistically significant
Improvement in Revenue um and the team
can now uh move move on from their
test so summary for winning over your
colleagues uh you need to promote your
colleagues adoption of your Solution by
designing userfriendly interface and
ensuring adequate support for adoption
so to do this we use the userfriendly
design but this was second step was
really important is that we chose to do
team by team interactive trainings
uh most data science projectss I see
rolled out they may have one or two Mass
trainings with three or 500 people
present that's not an environment where
people are going to ask vulnerable
questions or try to reconcile their
needs with what you're offering them um
Team by te interactive trainings these
are like 10 people or less uh people get
very comfortable asking those dumb
vulnerable questions uh that actually
ensure that they're going to feel
confident using the tool the second key
piece is that it's interactive uh if
you're merely talk Deb for an hour on
how to use an application there's very
low likelihood that you're going to
retain or feel confident applying any of
that we always use the show then do um
Rhythm so we would demonstrate a
capability of the app and then we would
have them for instance change the
primary metric and then perform the same
steps themselves uh this makes the
training a lot
stickier finally uh we offered ongoing
support in a slack channel uh sequential
testing
support um and I want to emphasize that
because we took those first two steps of
it was a userfriendly design and we had
provided adequate training we were not
overwhelmed with manua requests in the
slack Channel A lot of times the
questions we were getting in the slack
Channel were actually really provocative
uh or really you know uh exemplary
requests that other people could benefit
from seeing the the the conversation
around the tone in which you respond in
the slack channel is also going to set a
lot of expectation around whether people
are irritating you with their help
requests or whether this is a
collaborative effort uh that they're
participating
in um all right and I think you know if
you take these three steps it is a lot
more work than just doing you know rapid
roll out in a mass training but this is
what it takes uh you know to see
widespread
adoption okay so step three Implement
track and report so if leadership has
endorsed Your solution and your
colleagues feel empowered to use it
you're going to get widespread
adoption you need to be thinking ahead
and have a measurement plan in place
beforehand for how you're going to track
adoption rate and estimate the benefits
of your project so we reached 100%
adoption but now we needed to go back to
leadership and tell them well how do we
Faire against this goal to reduce test
duration by 25% and importantly what was
that
worth so the way that we did this was
that every sequential test under the
hood was Computing a fixed sample power
analysis so we weren't just going to
rely on simulations anymore we would
know for every single test how long it
actually took and how long it would have
taken if they had run the same analysis
in a fixed sample
test and what we found on average was
right in line with our simulations we
had an average savings of
63% and you can see in the negative
territory that some tests did run longer
uh but on average this was an enormous
Time Savings well exceeding our 25%
goal but when test ends 63% faster that
means that there's more time in season
for customers to enjoy the best
experiences so what we then did is we
calculated the incremental Revenue gain
from faster roll out on every sequential
test and so what you're seeing is it's
obviously the sequential test are on the
Y AIS the blue section is I should say
the full length of the bar is the
revenue associated with that roll out
and if you go back to the blue section
that's how much the revenue would have
been if we had done the delayed roll out
on a fixed sample
test so now we could sum up the green
incremental Revenue gain from sequential
testing across all of our tests and we
could report back that not only did we
save 63% TimeWise but that this method
had increased Revenue by 38% relative to
the methods that we replaced
so in my closing summary
um you can be among that 20% of data
science projects that go to production
uh if you influence your Leaders with
accessible terminology if you win over
your colleagues with accessible
design measure and Report out regularly
on your progress and there's one other
thing and that's don't go It
Alone um there are no 10x Engineers
there are no 10x data scientists but
they're absolutely are 10x
Partnerships so if you want to run 10
times as far and 10 times as fast find a
great running partner find a great
coach uh and then form a great running
club
so um thank you all for attending
today all right thank you Joseph so you
did A really lovely job of walking us
through that entire experience if you
did that again what would you do
differently um before you
launch make fake data representing
everything that you're expecting to come
into your pipeline this is for the
tracking piece that third piece and then
just make sure that all of the fake data
is making it perfectly into the lake
exactly as you expected this is so much
easier I would 100% delay release by a
week or to to be 100% confident that all
of the tracking is exactly as I expected
as you can guess we didn't do that and I
can tell you that like that one or two
weeks easily cost us two to three months
in trying to recover from uh just you
know violated assumptions not
statistical assumptions just assumptions
on how you thought the data was going to
move so yeah run fake data through the
pipelines before any release it's it's
like an iron clab Rule now on future
releases that absolutely nothing gets
released until we're confident that the
logging uh is in place okay fantastic
thank you let's thank all of our
speakers
[Applause]
again